ماده الشاب هو المخدرة لا تزال وراء
الكثير من الجرائم البشعه وحالات العنف في
السعوديه مع ملاحظه تزايد اقبال فئات
معينه على تعاطيها انتشر مؤخرا مقطع فيديو
لمواطن سعودي يعتدي على رجل امن ذكرت
الجهات الامنيان المواطنه قبض عليه وهو
تحت تاثير تعاطي ماده الشعب المخدره
هل وست وسلوك عدواني وجرائم بشعه خارجه عن
المالوف كلها ارتبطت في الاونه الاخيره
ارتباطا وثيقا بمتعاطى ماده الشابو في هذا
المقطع متعاطي لماده الشبو يعتدي على رجل
امن اثناء عمليه ضبطه بعد ان اعتدى على
عائلته وهددهم بالسكين في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض لكن قد لا يمر وقت طويل
حتى ينتشر مقطع مصور يشبه هذا او اعناف
يوثق جريمه صادمه لمتعاطي الشبو او مشهد
تمثيلي تبثه الجهات المعنيه يروي قصه
حقيقيه لمتعاطي الشبو وهو ينفذ جريمته
والتي كان منها حرق متعاطين لبيت العائله
ليقتل والده ووالده واخوته جرائم جعلت
الجهات المعنيه بمكافحه المخدرات تقوم
بحملات توعويه عن خطر هذه الماده والتي
باتت منتشره في الاونه الاخيره وتحديدا
بين اوساط المراهقين والشباب
ما هي ماده الشبو هي ماده كيميائيه لها
نتائج مدمره على الجهاز العصبي المركزي
للانسان والجهاز المناعي هذه الماده تصيب
متعاطيها باعراض نفسيه منها السلوك
العدواني والشعور بالقلق وفقدان القدرات
العقليه والاكتئاب الشديد والهلوسه
اما اعراض تعاطيها الجسديه تشمل الشعور
بالاعياء وتقرحات الجلد وفقدان الوزن فضلا
عن تسوس الاسنان وتساقطها كما تعرف بعده
مسميات منها الكريستال ميث والشبو والسابو
والثلج والجلاسميث وقد تاتي هذه الماده
على شكل مسحوق ابيض او حبوب واقراص وتقود
الى ادمان سريع اما رحله التعافي منها فهي
بطيئه وصعبه
الطب النفسي وعلاج الادمان الدكتور محمد
المقهوي دكتور محمد حياك الله معي في نشره
الرابعه دكتور كل عام وانت طيب مشهدناه في
الفيديو الاخير يعني هل هو بالفعل هل من
اثار تعاطي هذه الماده ماده الشعوب بمعنى
ان الانسان يتعطى يتعاطى هذه الماده هل
يصل في رده الفعل ربما الى مواجهه رجال
الامن كما تشاهدنا في الصوره
هذا الشهر الكريم وتقبل طاعاتكم الامر
الاخر اشكركم على تسليه الضوء على هذا
الموضوع
طرح كثيرا في الفتره الاخيره ومهما يطرح
ومهما يتكلم عنه حاجه ملحه جدا جدا ما
شاهدناه هذا الفيديو او ما انتشر من مقاطع
الامر الاخيره تقريبا بحكم عملنا في مجال
الادمان في مستشفيات اراده والصحه النفسيه
نشاهد اعظم من حوادث اعظم منها هذه الحاله
ماده التشكر في التقرير هي ماده كيميائيه
وهي ماده طبعا مصنعه ولها عده ولها عده
مسميات الشبو والكريستال
وغيره هذه الماده تشتغل على النواقل
العصبيه بالذات ماده الدوبامين وتؤثر على
نقاط معينه في الدماغ خاصه
الجبهي الامامي هذا الفصل مسؤول عن اتخاذ
القرارات بمعنى ان الشيخ عندما يتخذ قرار
هل هذا قرار صحيح ولا خاطئ هل بامكاني ان
اقدم على هذا الفعل او لا هناك منطقه في
الدماغ تحدد هذا الامر للاسف من تعرفون من
يستخدمون ماده الشبو يفقدون القدء هذه
القدره
فتصبح قدرات على اتخاذ القرارات والحكم
على الامور والتقييمها وتقييم العواقب صفر
فنجدهم فنجد من يقتل من يعتدي على رجال
الامن من يعتدي على الاسره الحوادث التي
سمعناها من قاموا باحراق الاسر من يعتدي
على نفسه
ومره علينا حالات
بسبب تعظيم لماده الشبو جيد
تاثيرها الان بهذا الشكل على المتعاطي
دكتور محمد
في تاثيرات جسديه منها اتباع في الحراره
ارتفاع في نبضات القلب
تاثيرها على الاسنان ممكن الوفاء بسبب
سكته القلبيه حالات بسبب جرعه زائد لماده
الشبوه في اللحظه ولا زلنا نشاهد تاثيرات
تظهر مع الاونه الاخيره خاصه ان هذه
الماده كونها ماده مصنعه فكثير فكثير من
وادي المصنعه يدخل فيها مواد اليها مواد
اخرى كما عمل في احد المختبرات الذين في
المنطقه الشرقيه عندما قاموا بتحليل مدى
الشبو وجدوا هناك مواد مضافه على هذه
الماده تجعلها اكثر خطوره من ناحيه
الجسديه من الناحيه النفسيه العصبيه
الانفعال التهور الاكتئاب احيانا قد يصل
الاكتئاب الى درجه شديد تصل به الى
الانتحار ايضا
جمعيه او بصريه ومن اشد الارض التي
نلاحظها عند البعض ما يسمى بالظلالات وهي
عباره عن افكار تكون عند الشخص وهي غير
حقيقيه مثلا
تريدون ان يضرونا
فبالتالي فبسبب هذه الافكار تدخل لديه
الجراه على الاخرين اذا عنده فكره ان فلان
يراقبني عليه فلان والله يريد ان يضرني
فانه
يعتدي عليه اعتقاد منه انه يحمي نفسه من
هذا الامر اضافه الى اضطرابات
الهلع وغيرها كيف شايفين دكتور حجم انتشار
هذه الماده الان ماده الشبو في السعوديه
والله الى قبل تقريبا
خمس سنوات كان كانت نسبه قليله جدا
نلاحظ تصاعد كبير في هذه الماده طبعا عده
اسباب اولا تصنيعها الامر الاخر
رخص ثمن هذه الماده
ايضا
متعاطين الشاب وفي الغالب متعاطى الشب لا
غالبا يبدا بمواد اخرى من ضمنها الكبتاجون
او ما يسمى او او الحبوب المنشطه في ظل
قله هذه الحبوب او هذه الماده بدا البعض
يتوجه الى استخدام ماده لاحظنا على المثال
بعض المراجعين في العياده بعض الذين
انتقلوا اذا ماده الشبوه عندما سالناهم
قال بسبب والله الكبتاجون غير متوفره
ارتفع سعره فبدا بعضهم التوجه الى ماده
التشابه طبعا ماده الشبو تعطي نفس تاثير
ماده او الحبوب المنشطه ولكن
بما يعادل خمسه او سبعه اضعاف في الشده
والاثار المدمره كيف يجب ان نتعامل مع
المتعاطي لماده الشبو ومتى ممكن الانسان
يدمنها يعني بعد اول جرعه
لعده استخدامات حتى يكون مدمن لهذه الماده
هذا الامر الاول الامر الثالث في التعامل
اولا نحذر من التعامل مع مدمن الشبوب في
حال تعاطيه مثل ما قلنا بعض الامهات
والاباء يعتقد انه سيحاول ان يستعطف هذا
الشخص واحنا اهلك وبطل ووقف في حاله هو
غير مدرك بتصرفاتك وافعاله واقوالك فننتظر
حتى يحدث
الى احد المصحات العلاجيه مجمعات للصحه
النفسيه في حال عدم التجاوب
هنا تقول الاسره مضطره للعلاج القسري
وهناك وزاره الصحه بالتعاون مع اداره
مكافحه المخدرات ووفروا ما يسمى بالعلاج
القصري من خلال الاتصال على رقم واحد تسعه
خمسه ورفع بلاغ يتم التنسيق مع المكافحه
واخذ هذا الشخص الى المصحه للعلاج ولا
يترتب على هذا اي اجراءات امنيه والله لو
بلغنا عليه قد يسجن قد والله يفطر في حكم
السجن او الاحكام مرتبطه في حاله انه انا
كان هناك اعتداء او ضرر على الاخرين لكن
اذا كان التواصل من اجل العلاج يتم
توفيرها بموانتها السريه طيب بعد العلاج
القسري بس في ماده الشبو ولا في كل المواد
وهل اسلوب وطريقه العلاج تختلف بين متعاطى
الشبوه وغيرها من المواد دكتور سريعا
الامر الثاني بالنسبه لطريقه العلاج
تقريبا اغلب
البرامج العلاجيه
تمر بمرحلتين ازاله السموم هذه تختلف من
ماده الى ماده مثلا عرض انسحابيه تختلف عن
السحابيه الحشيش فيكون معها اضطرابات مثلا
في النوم حلاوه فيعطي علاجات لتجاوز هذه
المرحله لتحسين النوم لتحسين
المرحله التاهيل والتي تمتد من ثلاثه اشهر
الى السنه